(laughs)
- "Marcus Makes a Movie", this is a book
that I decided to write
to inspire the youth.
The generation today, I feel
like the word no is powerful.
It's discouraging and
sometimes you do need a,
a little, a little push
and understanding that
no is not forever.
It's, it's a moment.
And this is the book of a guy,
a young kid that heard the word no
and didn't want to accept it.
And he wanted to create his opportunity,
which is what life is about.
It's about creating and
making opportunities,
making the best of them
and having the ambition, the
drive to do it, stay with it,
ultimately succeed.
For whatever that level of success is.
In this case, it was about
making his dream movie
that he was told he couldn't
do because he had no money,
he had no cameras.
And he found a way to do it
without having those assets,
but by just having the help
of some friends, ambition,
and ultimately a dream.
And the dream comes true,
but it's a nice journey.
It's a good journey.
And I want kids to understand,
that's what life is.
(clapping)
Life is a journey, a journey
worth living and embracing.
You know why?
Because at the end of it,
we all get to look back at our story.
And Marcus's story, it's amazing.
Wow, did I sum that up.
Hit me with it.
(laughing)
(drums beating)
Yes.
(laughing)
- That was awesome. I feel inspired.
- I'm crushing this.
- First of all right now...
- I'm crushing.
- What, what was your experience like?
I don't know, did you ever have,
were you ever told no about
something and then you feel like
you pushed through anyway,
that you could do it.
Somebody told you you can't
do something and you did?
- Well Kelly, first and foremost
let me take the time to
echo what you just said.
- Okay.
- Because Kelly that was a
great, it was a great question.
Right?
- Okay, I feel, I feel...
- I was told, I was told no.
- Okay.
- We all were told noes at
some point in time Kelly.
But here's the thing, my
noes ultimately became
my drive and want toward my yes. Right?
- Okay.
- I was told that I wasn't funny.
I was told that I wasn't going to make it.
- What jackass told you that?
- Several.
I was told that my movies
would never show overseas,
and do business overseas.
I was told the likelihood
of me being a movie star,
was not likely.
I was told everything.
- Wow.
- That is the complete
opposite of what I now am.
And here's the thing,
when I was told that I didn't
get angry, I didn't get mad.
I just used it as
personal fire for myself.
- Yeah.
- Because I believed in a certain thing
that I felt I had.
- You are Marcus.
- I am Marcus.
- Yeah.
- Marcus comes from me.
It comes from my life.
And my story, we just did it in a way
to where kids would be able
to identify with it as well.
- Yeah.
- But the word no, once
again, it's temporary.
It's not forever, man.
And that's the biggest thing that
I want this young generation
to truly understand.
- I love that, dream big.